blake shelton the sexiest man alive
apparently isn't so sexy birth um
Kelsey's was kind of getting me I'm
sorry Jason Momoa exists on the planet
so I thought it should have gone to him
but social media has not been kind to
Blake but one of the reasons that Blake
is sexy is the sense of humor right and
he's got the tweets to prove it
[Music]
woke up and saw Blake Shelton is the
sexiest man alive did a bunch of
celebrities die or something last night
Blake Shelton looks like the dad in a
drug commercial where they list off the
side effects at the end Blake Shelton
isn't even the sexiest man at this
Waffle House and there's a few other
mean tweets out there Blake forgot like
the sexiest thing about Blake Shelton is
Adam Levine the voice host Carson Daly
posted not sure about the sexiest but
congrats on the recognition of being a
man and being alive and then there's
this gem I don't think he's even the
sexiest man named Blake Shelton but what
does Blake's bestie Luke Bryan think
well eg online so fish Lacy caught up
with him and his fellow American Idol
judges last night I originally roasted
him about it but then I think now the
whole world is roasting in and now I
feel bad for roasting him anything he
was a man
item premieres March 11th on ABC Katy
Luke and line I'll have this piece of
advice if anyone auditions with any of
your songs and do you recommend that
tactic because it feels a little bit
like they're sucking up but yeah Katy
just actually just had it happen and
Katy's know though she's on she's going
under the table the first thing I said
to I was like your stage five clinger
aren't you
[Music]
you